christian jacob merci madame la
présidente monsieur le premier ministre
je dis nous avons voté la prolongation
de l'état d'urgence
nous avons également voté un
renforcement de la loi de 1905 qui va
dans la bonne direction
nous attendons pardon 1955 vous aviez
corriger nous attendons désormais la loi
qui perd qui permettra dans les plus
brefs délais de mettre en application
les propositions que nous avons faites
monsieur le premier ministre
à l'heure où le peuple français en terre
ses enfants il aussi toujours entre
recueillement émotions colère et
interrogation interrogations notamment
sur les parcs sur le parcours de ces
djihadistes dont certains étaient fichés
et qui ont pourtant commis l'irréparable
à paris nous leur devons collectivement
la vérité les flux les français
attendent également des réponses de
l'union européenne monsieur le premier
ministre
pouvez vous nous dire quelle position
précise défend la france quant à la
refonte totale des accords de schengen
et quel est le calendrier de l'adoption
du pnr ce fichier aérien dont les
français ne comprennent pas pourquoi il
n'est toujours pas en application la
guerre que nous livrons nous la
gagnerons ici en france nous la
gagnerons dans une europe qui acceptent
de se protéger
qui accepte de contrôler et de
surveiller ses frontières mais aussi en
frappant durement l'état islamique
là où ils prospèrent monsieur le premier
ministre et le second sujet sur lequel
nous souhaitons vous entendre le
président de la république va rencontrer
vladimir poutine jeudi demain notre
assemblée votre la prolongation de
l'intervention militaire en syrie
avec l'arrivée sur zone du charles de
gaulle la france est en situation
d'intégrer la grande coalition que notre
groupe parlementaire appelle de ses
voeux depuis deux ans
ma question est donc simple où en est
notre nouvelle stratégie d'alliance
diplomatique et militaire en syrie
merci merci le seul président la parole
est un premier ministre
madame la présidente monsieur le
président jacob ou font à travers votre
question vous avez rappelé que nous nous
battons sur plusieurs fronts même si
nous avons le même ennemi dèche que nous
voulons détruire parce que nous sommes
dans une guerre nous l'avons les uns et
les autres rappeler d'abord le front
intérieur par la mobilisation de nos
forces de l'ordre par les moyens que
vous nous avez donné à travers la
prolongation de la loi de 1955 celle de
l'état d'urgence que nous avons complété
qui permet perquisition nombreuses avec
évidemment des résultats sur lesquelles
je ne doute pas le ministre de
l'intérieur reviendra assignation à
résidence
plusieurs dizaines d'individus ont été
assignés à résidence
dissolution si c'est nécessaire et ce le
sera bien évidemment de groupements ou
de groupements de fait lié à l'islamisme
radical et au salafisme et puis
mobilisation du peuple français dans un
moment aussi de recueillement et vous le
savez vendredi il y aura cet hommage
national aux victimes et à leurs proches
auxquels bien sûr le parlement sera
associé qui sera un moment fort pour les
français parce que c'est la réponse
aussi que nous devons aux français il y
à la mobilisation sur le plan européen
et les positions sur lesquels reviendra
aussi bernard cazeneuve dans l'instant
concernant à la fois le pnr
indispensable et j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de le dire ici même il appartient au
parlement européen et à tous les groupes
de prendre pleinement leurs
responsabilités et chacun doit le faire
je parle de ma propre famille politique
vous savez là dessus c'est un combat que
nous menons depuis trois ans et chacun
doit prendre ses responsabilités et un
pnr qui soit effectif qui fonctionne
vraiment c'est ce que nous avons obtenu
à travers bernard cazeneuve à l'occasion
du conseil justice et affaires
intérieures
c'est les contrôles aux frontières comme
ce que nous effectuions et des deux
côtés et c'est évidemment la lutte parce
que c'est pour nous une priorité contre
le trafic d'armes et derrière cela
monsieur jacob parce que je crois que là
aussi vis-à-vis des français
nous leur devons vérité et
ans par ans c'est l'europe qui est
devant son destin face à la crise des
réfugiés d'un côté et à la menace
terroriste
l'europe l'union européenne doit
pleinement prendre ses responsabilités
nous en tout cas nous avons déjà pris
nos responsabilités et nous n'hésiterons
pas à prendre nos responsabilités tous
les pays et nous voyons bien aujourd'hui
avec la belgique doivent pouvoir faire
en sorte de protéger les frontières de
l'union européenne sinon il n'y aura pas
d'autre choix que de protéger pleinement
nos propres frontières comme nous sommes
en train de le faire et il faudra
poursuivre ce travail parce que nous
devons cette sécurité aux français et
puis évidemment il y a troisième front
c'est le même jean yves le drian qui
avec laurent fabius accompagne le
président de la république aujourd'hui à
washington pour cet entretien avec le
président obama l'a dit avec d'autres
mots mais je crois avec des mots très
justes nous combattons au fond une hydre
à deux têtes en france et c'est la
nécessité de pousser la lutte aussi
contre la radicalisation contre
l'islamisme qui est né dans notre sein
et puis à l'extérieur c'est le sens à la
fois des initiatives diplomatiques et
aussi bien sûr des frappes réalisés
depuis plusieurs semaines nous y
reviendrons demain
bien évidemment sur des cibles bien
particulière bien précises qui concerne
cette organisation déj l'état islamique
dès que j'ai des centres d'entraînement
des raffineries des camions qui
acheminent le pétrole bref ce qui fait
aussi la force financière de cette
organisation
c'est la volonté de créer une
coordination sinon une coalition pour
lutter contre des ch est là mais ça sera
l'occasion du débat de demain parce que
je vais conclure pour ne pas être trop
long c'est les attentats du 13 sur paris
qui ont profondément modifié la donne
nous n'avons pas changé de position
notre ennemi c'est dèche
nous constatons qu'au lendemain de ces
attentats la russie qui a été touché par
un attentat particulièrement graves
c'est à dire l'explosion de la
destruction d'un avion de l'une de ses
compagnes et a reconnu que c'était un
attentat nous constatons depuis le
dodi 13 que les informations entre les
états unis d'amérique et la france sont
d'une autre nature nous allons
poursuivre et c'est le sens des
initiatives du président de la
république aujourd'hui à washington
demain il rencontre la chancelière
merkel jeudi rencontrera le président du
conseil italien matteo renzi et le soir
il sera à moscou pour une rencontre
importante bien sûr avec le président
poutine
il aura l'occasion aussi d'aller au
sommet du commonwealth vendredi après
avoir rencontré le premier ministre
cameron hier
et puis la coke 21 le rendez-vous climat
sera l'occasion aussi de nombreuses
rencontres c'est toute la communauté
internationale qui doit se rassembler et
enlevant tous les ambiguïtés car nous ne
sommes pas très ambigu nous avons un
adversaire cedej et chaque pays et
notamment les pays de la région doit
venir tous et tous ceux qui sont
concernés par ce conflit que leurs
adversaires cédait ch et ne doutez pas
un seul instant que le président l'a
public à cette volonté faire en sorte
que demain
grâce à cette coalition grâce à cette
action grâce à la clarification des
positions de chacun cet ennemi des sept
organisations terroristes sera annulée
rémy nice premier ministre la parole est
un monsieur edwards